this is a it's always an exciting time
at Stanford it's a particularly exciting
time because I think this is by far the
best time to be graduating not the worst
let me tell you that change happens when
things are hard that the economy and the
situation that we're in now will create
phenomenal opportunities that are before
each and every one of you if you think
about it is is literally the best time
to graduate in 50 years assets are cheap
and expectations are set realistic I've
been teaching here in 3:54 with Peter
Wendel which is a true is literally a
treat of my life and I've watched the
quality and the commitment and the
capability of the students and it gets
better every year which i think is a
credit to the dean a credit to the
process but most importantly a credit to
you all so that's why I was happy to
come and talk what I wanted to do is
talk for a few minutes about the
political environment the business
environment and then and then really
talk about ideas and technology how
innovation occurs and then take your
questions which are probably much more
interesting than my comments if you look
at the situation politically first the
genius of the American system is that it
corrects and whatever you think of the
previous structure it's just being
corrected big time and I mean big time
and in one month enormous aspects of our
government are being redone one way to
think of it is it's a reaction sort of a
take take the country back from from the
middle class based on the excesses of
the previous sort of 20 years of wealth
creation it's obvious that the changes
that we're seeing both politically and
in the business world are not short-term
changes we have an opportunity in my
view to relearn
what creates real value and I would tell
you and hopefully without offending
anyone that real value is created by by
building real businesses that do new
things that matter to everyone at any
level of society and that one of the
things the Business School focuses on is
a lot of that one of the quotes that
became common in in the financial
circles that I spent a fair amount of
time in meetings over the last few years
is that in America financial innovation
precedes financial regulation ok I would
assert that this quote which you won't
find very high in rankings anymore is
now discredited and that we're about to
go through a very large change in in how
this works and in thinking about the
Obama presidency and of course I'm I'm I
was a strong supporter in this campaign
and have been an adviser the
best-case-scenario looks like the
Clinton presidency where for the next
couple of years
President Obama manages to do the things
that are necessary with hopefully the
right leaders and the right support from
Congress and so forth and the right
global structure to get everything going
and then there is an ascendant a couple
of years a reelection and so forth the
worst case scenario is that the
incentives and the structure and the
political structure that is always in
place in every political structure
somehow we don't overcome that and
somehow we does not turn so that's the
bet that he and others are placing the
best idea that I've seen so far is that
investment in the right areas creates
the necessary conditions to create huge
new businesses and huge new businesses
are how wealth is created how jobs are
created
how export aren't in businesses and so
forth are being created and there are a
number in the president's in the
president's plan but the important point
here is that we somehow forgot that
wealth is created by doing new things
that are technologically exciting that
scale and that are global and I hope
that as a society and as a country and
hopefully with the help of people like
yourself we can really do that but
there's another opportunity for us and
that's to learn a new idea and the new
idea has to do with transparency if you
look at a lot of the financial stuff the
problem today is the financial folks who
are trying the best they can don't
really know what's going on even though
the computers all know exactly what's
going on this is a failure of
transparency so how could you imagine a
system where you have all of this data
but nobody knows why well one is you say
well we'll let the regulator's manage
all of that well what's your defense
against regulators who are not funded
well enough or maybe not competent
what's your defense against against the
self-interest that occurs in all
governments republican-democratic
whatever whatever country and party you
care about the answer is transparency if
we had seen if we'd seen the details
that are now coming out there's a much
like a much greater chance that
responsible people working independently
either as critics or bloggers or
whatever structure the system would have
corrected quicker and we wouldn't be
going through the kind of crap that
everybody has to go through now which is
causing some real harm so the new idea
is that transparency is the best defense
against bad decisions and if I can send
one sort of non-technical message if you
can talk about transparency that we're
better off when we know what everybody
is doing at least with respect to how
the government works and how our
incentives work so in that context
what's happening is businesses and I
mean this in a general statement I've
said publicly for a while the business
situation is quite dire Warren Buffett
said this yesterday other people have
said it as well I'm certainly not the
only one who is saying this the fact of
the matter is that we're not at a bottom
yet that we've never faced
the depression a coordinated coordinated
if you will collapse or deceleration of
markets of the rate weaves name and at
Google of course we see this cuz we
talked to our customers and the ones we
don't have any particularly new insights
that you haven't already seen things
like travel and real estate and so forth
so our queries you know shift from
buying a house to refinancing a house to
hiring a you know a mortgage broker to
hiring a lawyer right that's the cycle
that people go and it's all part of it's
all part of what you would normally
expect but what's interesting now is
that and you have to have a plan it's
reasonable to expect that their recovery
that I had hoped and I'm an optimist in
these things would begin this year is
probably not until 2010 so that means
some number more of quarters of tough
business conditions which ever which all
of us are going to have to participate
in and we need to be honest about it but
maybe we can apply the the newly learned
lesson of transparency to get the data
out so that people can really figure out
when this thing finally turns recessions
and tough times force force these
decisions change comes during the
recession not in a period of
overwhelming abundance and so the good
news to the reader is one is now is when
real change will occur whether it's
investment in technology investment in
culture investment people and the reform
of institutions so so talking now about
technology and how how all this plays in
what are some examples of things that
could use some change well what are some
things that have been around for a long
time
how about computer architectures the
personal computer architecture all of
the ways in which at least that I grew
up with the biggest phenomena in in my
world is the transition to something
called cloud computing and cloud
computing what happens is you have
computers that are managed as servers by
Google and others and you pick up any
device you want whether it's your mobile
phone you know PC or a Mac or what
you and all that information is stored
on those centralized servers makes sense
right well I would like to think that
people are moving to cloud computing
because of the brilliance of our
architecture you know we did a great job
people love it it has all these new
features another possible explanation is
it's cheaper so sometimes change occurs
just because the model of the model in
technology is more is more scalable
sometimes it's because of a new feature
but changes are coming and it's coming
very quickly
in the case of of cloud computing it's
worth doing some math Moore's law and
people here tend to know know what
Moore's law is is roughly that the the
density of semiconductors can double
every 18 months density meaning the
number of circuits if you will and if
you follow that you do the math it means
that a roughly an improvement of a
factor of 10 every 5 years by the way
that means that in 10 years it's a
factor of 100 and in 15 years it's a
factor of a thousand ok
how big is a factor of thousand well a
three year old today when he or she is
18 will have a factor of a thousand more
of all of this faster networks more data
storage and all of that so what does
that mean I mean an example would be
that this this 18 year old give you know
on his or her high school graduation you
hand them an iPod or equivalent device
and you can put 85 years of video on
this device this person will die moorthi
actually watch all the video on the
device you just gave them you know these
were like some serious problems talking
about never being happy
you know a terabyte if you go to fries a
terabyte is $100 I remember when a
gigabyte was $10,000 and by the way how
big is a terabyte it's that big if
that's the size of the hard drive so
it'll be a petabyte for $1000 $100 in 15
years what will you put on it everything
so when you think about the possibility
there there's a possibility that
computer scientists kosta talk about an
inversion of architecture everything we
grew up assumed that networks were
unreliable and the computers were
reliable but in fact all the new
interesting activities are assuming that
networks are reliable because they seem
to work now really really well and
therefore we can build systems which
have thousands of computers where a few
of them can break and nobody notices
we've changed computer science to the
inversion of that what does this mean
for for you in a business it means that
you will end up being able to buy
computers that are collections of
unreliable parts but that by operation
will become reliable that breakthrough
is the breakthrough that Google is based
on because Google was built on PCs the
Dean talked about founding it at
Stanford
why did Larry and Sergey use pcs because
they were cheap at the same time people
were using supercomputers and many
computers to do the same things and they
figured out how to do replication now so
cloud computing
it seems obviously if you think about it
pick up any computer don't worry about
what's on it your calendar your personal
information all your documents are
managed centrally what are some of the
implications of that well it's a huge
crisis for software companies that have
been depending upon selling client
software and indeed they're all
attempting now to move to the web and
we'll see how successful it is obviously
including Microsoft
and but by changing their economic model
they have to come up with new ways of
making money but most people believe
that eventually most of that kind of
software will be free and it'll be
supported in other ways and that's
another huge disruptive change which
many of you are participating in when
you look at web services and advertising
supporting services and and so forth and
so on but the more the most non obvious
thing about cloud computing and it's
analogous the analogy I would offer you
is that when television first came out
the first shows were radio shows on
television and then they developed what
we think of today as television shows
the the non obvious thing about cloud
computing it's once you have all that
information on these centralized servers
there are a lot of things that you could
do that you couldn't do before right my
favorite example is Flu Trends so we
there's a lot of concern about pandemics
and the 1918 flu which is a terrible flu
killed equivalent of 50 million people
you know huge huge huge human suffering
in Google we can actually detect
anonymously rises in queries because we
centralized the servers and then we can
alert the healthcare professionals that
we think that there's an outbreak of flu
in their area and get them and the cycle
is about six months earlier this saves
somewhere between 10 and 30,000 lives a
year because we use it information to
get people ahead of the cycle there are
many many examples and you all you all
are very smart you can think about what
would you do if you could sort of watch
and you have to do it with permission of
course what people are doing think of it
as data mining and you need some level
of log retention so you understood of
understand at least something of what
people have been doing again you have to
do that within the law and within
permission but what's nice about it is
if you had all of those tools and the
reason I started with such a harsh
statement about the financial system is
that all of those systems were
architected in the old IT way had they
been architected in this new way we
would have seen this coming so much
quicker
and being able to address it in my view
so much more with so much more certainty
so following that lead when you when you
have all that data what could you do
with it well my favorite one is is the
the politicians BS detector right
politician is speaking right we're all
sitting here you all have your devices
you could type in what he or she says
and Google or equivalent will tell you
whether it's true or not I mean this is
like a real crisis for these guys you
know I mean at least it's going to
improve sort of the the sort of the spin
to be a lot more fact-based which I my
view would be an improvement okay well
that's fine so why don't we have a
little fun with that since every one of
these devices also knows where it is can
talk to each other why don't we just
have one of you type in what the
politician is saying and then everyone
can see the ranking of what the person
is saying or maybe you can do it over
here and you can do it over there for a
little while and maybe we can do it
together and maybe at the same time we
can have a social truly a truly intimate
social experience in these group
settings well we all have the shared
experience of a real time experience
with a politician so one way to think
about that is that for every experience
you have there's a query that you should
do and eventually we would like to be
able to do that query for you so that
you don't have to type it but that's the
kind of stuff that you can do when you
move to this new model so we're talking
about phones everybody here has a phone
I suspect you all have them with you
right now many of you have many phones
blackberries iPhones Android phones and
so forth and so on what's interesting
about these phones well they're more
pictures taken on phones than there are
in cameras by the way every one of which
is trapped in the phone forever because
you can never get them off it's a
separate issue every phone now has a GPS
in it for 911 services GPS or GPS
equivalent all the high-end handhelds
one kind of other have GPS and so forth
so if you have
and by the way these cameras are
becoming movie cameras mm-hmm that's
pretty interesting so on an Android
phone a couple of months ago somebody
built a product where you open up the
phone and you have it scanned where it
is it knows it's GPS coordinate it takes
a picture of all the buildings and then
using Google it tells you what's going
on in the buildings mmm oh that's pretty
interesting so all of a sudden you've
got a GPS and a camera and a
supercomputer in your hand
backed up by all the world's data so one
way to think about that is okay well
that's pretty interesting well why don't
we just walk down the street and since
my phone is my phone it's like the one
thing that you know I always have with
me it knows a lot about my behavior so
for purposes of argument I love history
so as I'm walking around since it knows
where as why doesn't it just do a search
to tell me the history of every building
that I passed and I'll let you think of
the more exciting applications than the
one I just gave you right but the
principle and that's a pretty big deal
because not only do you have the device
and the access to the information that
you have today but you also have all of
the information from everything around
you I can do a lot with that information
somebody else built a product where when
you walk into a store you hold up the
barcode and it tells you if it's cheaper
online so you can imagine what the
shoppers think about that you can
imagine you know the sign no cell phones
now they really mean it you know we can
the store so so they're about a billion
phones coming out in new people's hands
in the next three three and a half years
who've never had a phone before we've
never heard their voices
we've met we don't I don't speak any of
their languages we don't know what
they're gonna say to us but they're
gonna be heard and I think that is
tastic we're gonna hear those voices for
the first time in our society and our in
our culture what's another example of
something we can do so here we are and
we Stanford is founded you know more
than a hundred years ago and the model
has been forever that we sit here in
pretty comfortable seats and we have
textbooks what's another way you could
teach you could teach with with
Wikipedia couldn't you so I'll give you
my example of my friend Bill joy who's a
venture capitalist and a brilliant
computer scientist and I said well
what's it like being a venture
capitalist he said well I just use
Google I said give me a break and he
goes no no that's what I do I get
interested in something like I said like
what Bill and he goes hydrodynamics okay
typical Bill interest so he he starts
and he does a hydronium X query and he
starts reading the research papers and
he reads enough of them that he gets
interested in the piece of hydrodynamics
and then he finds all the papers and he
looks at all the authors that have
referenced each other he figures out who
the two or three best authors are and he
calls them and by the way these are
people who no one ever calls so they
call him back right
so and he talks to them and he says well
like what's the most interesting thing
in your field in every single idea that
he's had has come by finding the new
idea how could we use that here here at
Stanford for example well rather than
having a textbook we'll give you a set
of queries this is obviously
self-serving but you get the idea
we'll give you us how to give you a set
of queries now and your job is to do
your search before class you don't have
a textbook so now the one third of the
class that sits in the back they're not
gonna do anything right sorry maybe not
at Stanford but in a normal place you
would so they're gonna wait for everyone
else so what about the two thirds well
out of that two thirds some of them will
do we'll get interested in something
hydrodynamics or whatever it is you care
about and you'll become the world's
expert in preparing for a single class
and the other people will get it wrong
and then you have a classroom
conversation and eventually people get
to the right answer
think about the modality of teaching is
very very different because you've got
all the information in one place and you
have all of this access and it's all
tied together in this very very new way
what's interesting now is that user
information is becoming authoritative if
I gave you a choice between a friend of
yours sending you an email saying the
following thing occurred on news or you
are waiting to the evening and turning
on the evening news which do you think
is the primary way in which you get news
now it's from your friends it's a huge
issue for the news industry I'm going to
come back to that but the explosion of
user what is generally known as user to
user content or user-generated content
is not something that's going away and
whether it's Facebook YouTube all the
Digg and Twitter services and so forth
all of those things are really about all
of us participating in a broader
conversation user to user and without
the intermediaries we love it the
intermediaries are being
disintermediated and it's a very real
crisis for them so so here's another
example of what you could do well we
have Wikipedia and Wikipedia is a
nominal achievement of mankind it is one
of the greatest things I have ever seen
it's amazing to me that Jimmy and all
those people have managed to keep it so
accurate in the face of so many of the
of the worst sort of human impulses as
well as the best imagine the same thing
for doctors we have 16% of American GDP
goes to the medical industry doctors
typically are not very current on
information they typically aside some of
the best places don't have a lot of
information and they're very very busy
so why is there not the equivalent of a
wiki med where the doctors essentially
collaborate it not only talked about the
sum of all the treatments but treatment
outcomes and so forth and why is that
database not both transparent to
themselves but also to api's where
programs can then suck that data and
then do outcomes measurements and things
like that it's obvious that such a
system should be built the same thing
should be true for any technologically
sensitive scientific or analytical based
field can you imagine if you had the
same thing about the financial world and
we had been able to use that to monitor
the things that it would happened over
the last five years in the in the
broad-based global financial industry
think about how different we would be in
terms of knowing where we were and what
we'd have to do so once again it's the
union of the all the world's data the
mobile phones and the ability to have
users that really I think will drive
this thing forward so search which of
course is what Google does first and
most changes it becomes much more
personal because now we know much more
about who you are and what you want and
this again is this all has to be said
with your permission because people most
people are happy to give you that
information but some people are not so
an example would be why is it my classic
example is my turn of the television why
does the television show me shows that I
saw yesterday
what a stupid television it's my
television it doesn't it know to delete
that show and show me a different show
well in search it's easy for us to do
that we know what you read we know who
you are
we can show you new stuff show me what
change tell me what is new today
remember what I looked for yesterday and
then suggest something I should look for
today tell me what my friends are
looking at again if they are willing to
tell me I suspect most would but not
some of my friends probably wouldn't
right but that's ok we can do that now
because of the interconnectedness of all
of all of this but maybe in that model
search can then morph at least somewhat
in to entertain me because ultimately
entertainment drives a lot of learning
and a lot of outcomes and a lot of
activity just as well as the analytical
nature of search today and at the same
time I think we need to take back the
web I don't know about you but I'm tired
of the spam problem I am tired of these
and I've called it publicly the sewer
problem of the Internet when we worked
and I was privileged to work on the very
beginnings of the Internet way way back
as a very young programmer it never
occurred to us that people would come in
who were both evil or crazy or both
showing you how naive we all were and
again that's a separate separate subject
but the fact of the matter is that the
web now has this very large component of
idiots right who basically they really
there's a reason why they're at home in
the basement and and then a term you
could invent called disinformation
basically information that looks
legitimate but is in fact manipulative
is being paid for and it should be
possible for us to detect both those
categories now with better ranking and
better understanding and better user
involvement to really show you the very
best parts of the web so in this model
advertising remains the is likely to
remain the primary source of revenue for
much of the monetization here of course
Google is heavily in that business as
you all know you can imagine remember
ads are valuable if they're useful
why does my television it's easy to yell
at my television because it's passive it
doesn't talk back right
sorry the the ads on television repeat
and furthermore they're the same ad so
you show a baby products ad in a home
that has no baby in it it's a complete
waste to the advertiser so a targeted ad
makes sense but in this new generation
of ads we can also do dynamic and
interactive ads so as a result we can do
things that are much more narrative and
ultimately advertising is about
narrative and about compelling people to
get excited about something the
technology is now getting strong enough
that we can actually do that we're
building an ad exchange for display
advertisers so that in fact all those
ads that you see you can put in one
place and then you can suck the
appropriate ad to make that happen
and so think of it as that you know the
ad for expresso machine not only should
it show you a picture but it should also
talk about the ad and be it have a video
and have a user content and be able to
buy we think we can make a lot of money
and of course everybody can make money
with this sort of approach so if you
imagine that then think about the
integration the historic separation
between enterprise and consumer in
computing doesn't make a lot of sense
people are the same whether they're at
home or at work they want the same
powerful applications at home and at
work
the separation existed because of
security and because of the sort of
notion of how the chief information
officer operated 20 years ago in
client-server computing which is a very
different world
so with client with cloud computing it's
now possible to have the same apps at
home and at work and still have the same
level of security of the corporation
depends that becomes the future of
enterprise applications
that's why software as a service has has
it has in fact survived after a lot of
initial attacks by a lot of incumbents
and looks like it's going to become the
primary way in which enterprises consume
applications partly because of cost and
cost is always a benefit but also
because the benefits of scale and the
benefits of sharing when you have in
your company you have everyone in the
one same place you get the same benefits
so sharing of calendars simple things
like that would you say oh no big deal
huge deal
huge issue in terms of productivity in a
corporation so maybe we should set the
goal higher than we that we already have
and maybe we should set the experience
of the internet as easy as reading a
magazine that seems like an odd I'm not
talking about magazines and the Internet
of the same thing but there's a reason
why magazines work really well they're
beautiful
they're the right size you can scan them
real quick you can really understand
them very quickly and you can deeply
read them at the same time that shift is
the next technological shift in speed
and structure of the internet and if you
think about the speed feel and beauty
you'll get there Kindle is a good Kindle
and Kindle two are a good first step
along that way and although although the
Kindle lacks many of the features of a
magazine it shows you that there's a
path and again do the math do the
thousand times math and you'll see that
that will be very much part of our
future in some form so what happens to
Radio internet and broadcast television
newspapers well radio of course is now
internet and broadcast at the same time
television is internet cable and
broadcast at the same time and
newspapers look like gonna be pretty
much all online over a long enough
period of time because of costs
primarily so what does this mean what's
the new thing you can do well the most
obvious one is you gonna have live
concerts streaming fan videos onto the
stage while the performers playing with
some censorship I assume now why would
you do that as a performer because it
would get your fan base going wild
but every one of those people in that in
that audience has a phone with a GPS
that's identified with them and a video
camera and you can transmit it and you
can put it on stage what's another
example
why don't you could have movie theaters
with instantaneous group Twitter's where
everyone is watching the movie and
talking about whether it sucks or not
right do you think that would drive more
attendance you betcha because we're
social creatures this whole concept of
Bowling Alone missed the fact that the
Internet is a fundamentally social
medium and that we finally now we as
society are finally taking it over to
drive it in this sort of new social way
so what happens then to content well if
you have something where your audience
is going to be 2 billion you're going to
use advertising if you have something
where your audience is going to be 2
million you're probably going to want to
use some form of micropayments
and the next generation of payment
systems are in fact will allow
micropayments 1 cent 3 cent as opposed
to the current payment systems which
sort of don't really work at that level
and then of course if you're if your
audience of content is 10,000 or 20,000
very highly skilled professionals you're
gonna charge them a subscription fee and
it's gonna be high 1 and they're gonna
pay it because your content is so good
all of those models will evolve what
happens to philanthropy with this well
all of a sudden now you can get all of
your all of your donors in one place
people here are doing that but you can
also imagine systems that that optimally
combined a web experience and a field
operation and the most interesting
philanthropy in my view will be the
building of a platform using the web
using the data using all the things that
I'm talking about building that platform
to do something that then is delivered
by people in the field whether this is
medical related health-related science
related or political freedom related as
the examples you can imagine many others
why do I mention this in this context
because we've not really applied the
benefits of Technology to the NGO and
the other worlds at the scale that we
should have but now we can because the
prices are low enough and the hunger is
there and it's all user the user
why is all of this so very very hard
I'll finish up finish up in a sec why is
this so very hard well almost everything
I've talked about there's an incumbent
who's really struggling now I as a young
scientist I used to think well you know
it's really new technology everyone will
just sort of welcome it but there are
many many powerful forces that oppose
the adoption of new technology it solves
a new problem in a way that's cheaper
starting usually with the incumbent
often they're very nice people by the
way it has to do with the fact that
they're incentivized around an existing
business model and under the thesis that
change occurs in a crisis
sort of what we're going through now now
is when you're gonna see these models
change literally in the next year that's
how quickly how long does it take for
some of these how long will it take
before television in one form or another
will become available as available on
your mobile device as it is on your
traditional television five years ten
years I don't know but it's coming and
you can feel it there are startups now
that will for example watch cable and
also watch the internet at the same time
and then give you a selection of shows
and then combine a DVR so that you have
control over when you view them all
perfectly legal and working and licensed
in the appropriate ways as people learn
this model they use your wins and they
get control and those things will be on
those devices I'd like to end by saying
that I think the right tone here is one
of optimism not pessimism everywhere I
turn the it gets the point where you
should just have to turn the news off
every day because it's a race to the
bottom in terms of morale this crisis
and that crisis and that and so forth
and people are trying every leader that
I know globally is trying very hard to
address this they're working very hard
I'm not criticizing them at all but the
fact of the matter is I think we should
view this not as a terrible situation
but rather in an optimistic context by
understanding that is that it is the
nature of innovation that has gotten us
these amazing things that I'm talking
about and that innovation which is
centered really here at Stanford right
as as the the Dean talked about how
phenomenal Sanford's contribution has
been it's not stopping the quality of
innovation is if anything getting better
there's a quote about America from mr.
de Tocqueville 1831 the America and he
as a Frenchman who travelled around I
can't do it in French unfortunately you
travel around America writing about the
American culture and spirit and he said
that America will do well because of its
abundance of land the sunny optimism of
its people and its absence of a king
everything I've talked about today is a
reflection of that the absence of a king
the change of government a change of
priorities the optimism of the creative
people and the tremendous resources that
we have whether it's in renewable energy
high technology or innovation or what I
consider to be the most important
resource which is the great universities
of which Stanford is one of the one of
the by far the greatest so with that
thank you very much
you have a question thank you you spoke
about your naivete at the start of the
Internet the world wide web and many of
the physicists who created nuclear
science were dismayed at Hiroshima and
Nagasaki so your description of the cell
phone as the supercomputer camera and
GPS system almost makes you want to just
like destroy my cell phone right now so
they're cheap you could get a new one or
create a new one but I'm just wondering
you know so how do you feel about the
fact that you could be creating you know
a super weapon of control and
information and how does that dialog go
in the upper echelons of Google and also
cross in DC we talked a lot about this
question and the good news about
networks and the technology is that it's
highly unlikely that the sort of the
centralization model of you know my
supercomputer being used for evil
purposes it's highly unlikely that will
occur because the technology and the
networks are so decentralized so the the
issues of misuse which i think is what
you're really getting at have much more
to do with the kind of evil that can be
done on the net where it's whether it's
password
whether it's identity theft which really
does have very significant victims or
virus things or worse we worry at Google
that people will publish information
that can be used to harm others there
are places in the it is for example in
the United States legal to publish
information that you we don't really
want you to publish but it's still legal
so those are things that we worry about
a lot and a nexus ID will adjust if
anything really bad happens I think I'm
not as worried about it as others
because I understand the net is
decentralized more questions yes sir you
talked a lot today about the power of
using a person's past behavior or past
expressed interest in providing more
precise content results even television
entertainment I'm wondering how you
think about the ability to still
maintain the discovery process someone
called the serendipity factor when those
things become more precise and I think
some would probably argue that
serendipity is actually
enabled by what we might consider error
or fuzziness of results
the example that I the easiest example
for that as newspapers that half of
newspapers are stories that you
desperate want to read and the other
good part of newspapers are the stories
that you should have been knowing about
but you didn't and yet you read them and
now you love them
that's the serendipity part it's
relatively easy to to bias the systems
for one or the other you could have the
highly targeted part and then the
serendipitous part we have we have a
historic thing called I'm feeling lucky
you know where we do the best we can for
you and then see if you like it so there
all sorts of variants of that I don't
worry as much about the over targeting
because that whatever happened whenever
we over target something there's such an
explosion of other choices that our
accuracy declines so the good news is
there's so much new information coming
in that we won't end up over specifying
the solution which is I think what
you're really getting at ultimately the
products that I'm talking about will
have a serendipity section and a highly
targeted section to allow you to make
the choice of do I want to be surprised
or do I want to see what I want to know
it's not for us and I don't think it's
for you all to judge whether people
should be serendipitously surprised or
see the things that makes the most
comfortable the great thing about
humanity is they get to make that choice
and will let them choose it some more
questions ok Google is undisputed leader
in search that's not everyone but can
you talk a little bit about competition
and particularly Microsoft and their new
search engine kuhmo thank you well
Microsoft has have a series of
announcements of new search engines in
the time that I've been at Google and so
far they've they've what can I say that
it would be polite I won't comment on
their lack of previous success
hi I'm curious what you view as the
significance of a search query in itself
what it can tell you about the world
around us is a predictive of behaviors
there's some great social meaning or
does it just really depend on whatever
search term you're looking at there's a
lot of evidence that we can use the
aggregate of search terms to predict
things both individual and so forth
there's a real issue if we start to use
that to to try to profile people or
things like that so we're real careful
not to get too far down the path that
you're describing this the obvious
scenario is you've got somebody
searching for breast cancer there's a
some probability that either they or a
loved one has it that kind of thing and
so we worry a lot about the misuse of
that information that's why I was very
careful whenever I talked about
personalization to say with your
permission and I think otherwise if you
don't do it that way people will move
away they won't they won't give you that
kind of information they won't give you
their most intimate if you will search
queries a lot of the future applications
of the web that you were talking about
depend on the level everyone is enjoying
your outfit depend on the benevolence of
people's people so for example wiki med
actually requires doctors to take time
out of their day a huge opportunity cost
to actually donate this knowledge base
so without paying for content how can
you encourage that continued benevolence
when presumptively people would look at
Google and say they're making profit
while I'm not but I'm contributing I
understand the question and I actually
just disagree with the reasoning so if I
may experience is the inverse the
experience is that when people see a
legitimate activity that will make the
world better
the high principle people will take the
extra time to make it better I think
that's what wikipedia proves we've seen
example after example of completely
selfless devotion of information
publishing monitoring all of that both
in Wikipedia but in other in other
activities as well I have every reason
to believe that if you have a legitimate
place in other words one which is well
least and not full of idiots and the
kind of thing that people will take the
time to share their knowledge and
experience it's one of the greatest
things about about about humanity people
really do care about making the world a
better place and I think you see it you
really do when you look for the high
quality sites here I was wondering you
talked about a lot of no outfit today
but um you talked about how you know if
there was more transparency if there was
sort of cloud IT in the financial
markets we would have alleviated this
problem that politics education the
voices of billions are gonna be heard
with better technology and I know that
when you have a hammer like Google you
see a lot of nails but to me these
problems are a lot more social and the
technology can't really fix them just
because some guy in the middle of some
rural area has a cell phone that doesn't
mean that the world is hearing his voice
it just means he can talk to his friends
who are equally marginalized so how do
you see technology as just one piece of
a puzzle where the other factors are
actually much more important again with
respect I just disagree with the thesis
let me argue that Ted Turner should be a
hero of everyone in this room because
Ted Turner pioneered the use of
commercial satellites which created CNN
which caused dictators to make it much
less likely for dictators to randomly go
kill a hundred thousand people because
they were being watched so there's a lot
of evidence that now with cell phones
and cameras and so forth some of the
greatest abuses against humanity are
less likely to occur because they're
more likely to be recorded so that's
anything that would be an exact count or
example to your to your first point this
the second point is that let's use the
example of Iceland which is a Tsar a
beautiful place with a sorry banking
system
at the point when Iceland's been stock
market was three-quarters valued with
three banks that was too late for them
to make the regulatory changes it was
just too late for them to make the
regulatory changes had there been much
more aggressive transparency with what
was going on had there been much more
active social conversation had there
been people in the country and outside
who kept saying hey hold on what's going
on and so forth had there been much more
active citizen involvement the
regulator's who have since lost their
jobs I should add would have been under
greater pressure to make the changes to
slow that phenomena down so I'm not
arguing that technology solves these
problems because I view these problems
as fundamentally political what I am
arguing is that technology allows the
citizens who are ultimately the victims
to put more pressure on the powers that
be that what's going on what are you
doing about it and I think that that
that transparency broadly defined is a
big deal some more questions
my question is some one related to what
you were is in but in the near future do
you see the internet applied to
government in a way that would allow a
more direct democracy by effectively
allowing the citizens to be somehow
involved in day-to-day decisions of the
government affairs it's I think it's
unlikely the internet will be used for
direct elections although there are
people who are proposing that excuse me
the there have been a couple proposals
in the new administration that I think
makes a lot of sense the first is
everyone knows how the Congress works is
that there's no smoke-filled rooms
they're just dark rooms now where
everybody gets together and they hash
out and they make a change in a
paragraph and that change you know
deletes you know super key you know
basically an aircraft carrier or adds
one these sorts of things and in the
negotiation wouldn't it be better if the
markups were on a public board where you
could see the changes from the point at
which the legislation
was first written to its final outcome
the only people who would be opposed of
this oh good if you of course to be the
politicians because that's where all the
bad stuff happens is where all the
lobbying activities and the earmarks and
so forth so that's an example of
something that's being talked about
right now another example is that much
of the government operates publicly but
without a lot of access because people
don't know that they have to go to the
country the conference room so another
thing that you could do is you could
have a rule that every public room had a
some form of HD camera and it was
streamed onto the Internet so that
literally if you cared about something
and you're sitting in whatever state
you're in you could watch the hearing
and then you can get excited or get
upset about what's really going on in
your government I don't think that the
tools of communication have been used
very effectively by government Andy
Grove who taught here for many many
years and as a hero of mine said that he
you know he's very analytical as you say
there's a formula and I said what's the
formula and and he goes well hi-tech is
three times faster than normal business
and government is three times worse than
normal business and speed so I said it's
a factor of nine slower and that may
indeed that may indeed be part of the
problem yes sir I think many of us are
interested in the clean tech and energy
space here and I'm sorting a few comment
on Google's kind of ambitions and vision
for power meter and then anything else
in the energy sector that Google's
involve a lot of people here I think are
aware of the renewable opportunity the
issues of climate change my own views at
that area
aside from nuclear proliferation those
are the two climate change and nuclear
brothers proliferation of a two ways in
which we can harm the most number of
people unless we act and act responsibly
in Google's case we're spending money to
help create the market so we're
investing in startups that do various
forms of renewable energy I think quite
successfully we ourselves are large
users of energy and so it's important
that we behave responsibly we've been
criticized for this but I would argue
and I think the data will show that
green energy will ultimately be very
good business today it carries this sort
of stigma from 20 years of subsidies to
the oil and gas industry but in fact
done right and with the kind of
technology that's being invented here at
Stanford and others we really will be a
great business in Google's case that's
the setup for what Google is doing which
is around the smart grid and simple
answer there is that if you look at
power distribution the most expensive
power is the peak power which is in the
middle of the afternoon in the summer
day so imagine a grid which understood
how to do all the necessary shift and
power and conservation to mark to
marginally change that literally to use
the battery that's in your car to power
your house so you use less from the grid
and then charge it at night the dynamic
power controls that can be done within
the home the sum of all of that could
very very significantly reduce the need
for power and a particular electricity
because the the marginal power is the
one that's the most polluting and it's a
very big opportunity another example
would be that with respect to power
meter most studies indicate that if you
give somebody a power meter their
electricity consumption just goes down
10% because they have something which
tells them what the number is the
analogy is that today in your house you
use power just like going to the
supermarket and not knowing the prices
of anything you buy until you get to the
checkout stand you know it's time for us
to fix this it's obvious that's what
we're doing more questions yeah I want
to the point you mentioned about you
know essentially that the intermediaries
and the dissemination of information are
going away if you have the cloud you
know and I have my cell phone and
everybody else's their mobile device
they can take the information capture it
publish it and receive it you know this
makes news agencies and cable news
networks and you know other other
intermediate publishers obsolete so my
question is in the kind of medium and
and in near term what are some of the
specific obstacles that you think Google
is is going to face with regards to that
and how are you going to address those
well first I don't agree that the
intermediaries become obsolete
I think the intermediaries have to
change their model much of the media
distribution so much of the media
industry is organized around both create
the creation of content as well as the
distribution of content and the
distribution of contact was built based
on the principle
scarcity in other words windows and you
can't have it now you have to wait it so
we're all familiar with this you know
DVD movies and so forth and it's true of
all of them and the problem with the
Internet is it does not fundamentally
believe in scarcity the internet
believes in abundance it's built around
that principle so you have to change
your business model so that you have
what I call mac strategies where you
maximize your distribution you maximize
your premise you maximize how you make
money and then you do you use either
advertising and so forth so the problem
that we're all going through now and I
live this every day because you have an
old model which is based on scarcity and
you have the partner or the person suing
you in our case I'm trying to move to an
abundant an abundancy model thank you
very much for your talk sure much of
what you said strikes me is talking
about kind of the services that Google
provides and I think a lot of the
questions are around that but I think
the truth of the matter is is Google's
an advertising company and I've heard a
lot of said about kind of the expense
out of the equation but not the revenue
side and I'm kind of curious about how
do you feel about that and if you have
more to add about that
why revenue what do you actually mean
you mean well I mean all these services
that Google provides requires some kind
of funding so that you can write well
first place we we do subsidize free
products by our advertising model and
search product search is is you know
it's a goldmine and in that sense
because it's so highly targeted so the
way we like to think about it is that we
make the most amount of money with the
most targeted advertisement ultimately
what happens to prices well our prices
are set by a second price auction so
they're set by and dissolving well
well-studied
those prices hit the substitution point
where eventually those prices are the
point essentially the cost bracket the
cost per acquisition that the advertiser
is willing to give in our case we use
tools to actually publish that number to
the advertiser so from our perspective
it's a closed loop system you know how
much you want to spend for an for a
customer we can give you the math to
solve that
that number grows and it grows as a
combination of both the skill with which
we do targeting and also at the grow
that rate which the internet grows and
also it grows based on the shift from
offline which is not so measurable to
online so we live in a complex equation
that roughly solves to that the good
news is it's a very very lucrative model
when run well so so with that you know
thank you for having hosting me